i am no costume designer however i
believe that all of you in the costume
designers guild have made an excellent
and perfect selection in choosing your
spotlight award and recipient this year
andrew garfield
andrew would be the first to tell you
that donning the clothing of a character
the outward representation of that
character settles you
into a sense of that person immediately
now please welcome the remarkable the
extraordinary the infinitely talented
and wildly generous andrew garfield
i know i wasn't supposed to cry this
evening
and and judith
just made me do that and um i'm just so
surprisingly overwhelmed and touched
to be in this room with
my community and
so many collaborators that i love and i
value that's another aspect of
of what you all do is you create a
container a respite a kind of
a safety code you are my favorite people
to collaborate with you are the truly
the best i feel like the luckiest most
fortunate actor alive you've given me a
big task to not get big headed after
tonight and i promise you i'll do my
best to pop pop the bubble when i get
home because i want to just keep working
and i want to keep collaborating and
serving something greater with you all
thank you for your art thank you for
your hearts
and for your generosity i hope we get to
just keep creating together thank you so
much i love you thank you